Jill Duggar is speaking out after facing
some major backlash how do you think
they'll react the 28 year old counting
on star just shared a bunch of pics from
her fifth anniversary trip with her
hubby Derick Dillard I was vetted we're
excited
including these shots at dinner at a
concert and at the movies but it was
this photo from inside their hotel room
that had people up in arms scary to me
that's a Kama Sutra book a massage oil
candle and a score sheet that has a
bedroom edition written on top fans were
fast to come after Jill for the sexy
snap specifically her promotion of the
Kama Sutra which is an exotic text based
on Hindu concepts that features chapters
on both same-sex relationships and
adultery in response to the comments
Jill edited her caption to explain the
controversial pic quote we are not
recommending the Kama Sutra the little
book pictured is a modern smaller
cleaner edited version we've not read
the actual Kama Sutra and only promote
biblical marriage ie between a man and a
woman who are married Jill's post came
shortly after she shared an essay titled
more than sex how to love your husband
where she recommended that couples have
sex often quote you both need this time
together regularly three to four times a
week is a good start
lol